yooz devancé squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur dix secondes tony jaa afin de
jouer un petit job à 10 secondes pour
tuer tous les robots sur la mappe fois
de plus simple à expliquer pas jouer
banon au monde où un robot lourd soldats
c'est moi votre chien fait que la torre
robot hitler 9
j'ai plusieurs choses à vous dire tout
d'abord certains parmi vous tweete
pendant nos réunions dire ça c'est pas
bien pour les punir a il faut détruire
le ninja semoun hidjab c'est parti
attends attends attends à le monsieur
une étoile pour le premier niveau sur
trois c'est nul à chier
attention c'est parti oui ou à nu je te
7 sur l'épique merci le succès le succès
du nul des piquets encore des pics
morisson un poids 1
c'était pour le domaine vous l'avez vu
ta ta ta ta ta mais [ __ ] world met un
petit coup de saab et non je vais partir
sur un barbecue avec cet homme n'a pas
marché alors dit moi on y va oui
hop hop mais on est alors regardez moi
ça on n'a qu'une étoile à chaque fois
elle vous calmer hockey au plat en
lâchant je suis mais galan aux plats à
l'epic salut aux professionnels et je
débloque un million de succès mais c'est
que des succès pour les news genre mûri
120 me de pouvoir ces tests ils s
étaient stylet mais malheureusement on a
une étoile est personne me critiquent
une étoile mais en plus les bruits
diamant belge ça que j'ai réussi on n'a
pas le temps jean michel pas le torrent
lingerie hope l'epic allez salut
oreilles c'est vraiment je m'en suis
allé comme ça c'est comme ça puis comme
ça puis comme ça et puis d'un coup comme
ça deux étoiles vous avez vu ça on dit a
indiqué à l'ats je le sens la cacoule
apparaît progressivement vous avez vu ça
deux étoiles que demande le peuple
je vous le dis ah merde en fait on ne
bouge pas le chrono ne part pas au kenya
je me suis enflammé mais non aux plats
aux plats au narrateur il faut deux
étoiles de plus pour pouvoir faire le
dernier niveau je le sentais ou des
baisers aux plats aux plats aux plats au
plat non je me suis trompé
c'est rudi sabran l'étoile suivante je
réessaie sans que voilà et au méchoui
cas ce week-end comme la piscine
comptage des papillons aulas rien non
monsieur le papillon ce qu on ne peut
comparer deux piscines bordel à homps
assure michel pall temps monsieur 0,06
calais fox voulait le défier vous avez
défié j'ai raté voulez monsieur 11e
défier j'ai pas rater deux étoiles
c'est quoi ces impasses auxquelles j'ai
pas ce week-end mais y aller comme ça
aux quais bas rive à l'autre côté
survival da cunha au plat le job tu
dégages je suis mort ok ce paraphe la
forêt on l'a fait monsieur c'est l'heure
du canyon on se fait massacrer ici on a
besoin que faites-vous je peins mais
vous n'avez pas de bras ou héliostats
drôle c'est parti au c'est nouveau ça y
est passé avant au plat ou plat
olala mais l'homme garde tous et
shurik'n quoi oui ou non mais on va
avoir le 3 étoiles je vous le dis vous
avez dit que moi je mens jamais hop hop
hop on en parle comme ça
toutes les étoiles c'est une question de
rapidité 2 po et plume et brad et moi
mon but n'est ce pas comme dans dbz
olalala complique witt et de la chose
wahiba à eau les [ __ ] et oui
messieurs une étoile nul on est en
europe et ses petits rats mais regardez
ce petit rebond dès que la balle est
arrivée je vous le dit aïe retour à
l'expéditeur expression nul et tac bas
on est quand à lui nettoie niveaux
suivants bas tout est ok je pense qu'il
faut esquiver et aller dessus
directement bien viser oui au nom j'ai
atteint ce week end c'est pas grave mais
dans mes mains allez montez pêche toi
heureux mais savoir ce message est un
message fort et de bombes
il vous faut 6 étoiles en plus si on
accuse et wal mart ou marvel est comme
ça hop hop hop hop hop hop
comment faire plus vite en plein au plat
non j'aurais dû garder ce week-end pour
là haut tant pis salut au peuple aux
plats en train de craquer non plus le
pire c'est qu'il faut juste eu ce qu'il
sait pas je rage en commun la même
sphère mario et tous deux trois quatre
cinq et de 22 mai qu'il a en même temps
c'est énorme et de seconde celle pas le
temps be my baby mme jeffrey jean-michel
pas le temps je ne sais pas
0,18 immense jean michel pall tant que
le pouvoir de tons pâles temps soit avec
nous quoiqu'il c'est parti
cette rapidité dans les mouvements vous
la sentez laquelle vous lui dites chat
écrasé telle une vieille merde
ah non comment vous voulez faire plus
rapide c'est impossible regarder
messieurs dames les deux shows ricaner
tout reste à 10 mois suivant mdp
s'il manque des étoiles banon mais
pourquoi je vous prenait la tête des
lions de l'atlas est juste de foncer en
fait voilà pas du tout comme ça trois
étoiles 3 étoiles au boss what you're
gonna to one week before champomy vous
en voulez vous avez des atouts but donc
on a eu plus des toiles aux canyons que
à la forêt est ce qu'on est nuls oui on
voit que hp ou poser une question
pourquoi compliquer votre moustache
ainsi la question taboue de ouf
alors du coup là ça glisse au [ __ ] le
fdp de stalactites obama est l'un des
condamnés ita tard ok j'ai mis les deux
dards même côté c'est la seule feuille
ça me fera quand je me concentre mon
cerveau il dit battue ne parlera plus
puisque tu es concentré up
ah non sur banc de neige quelques trolls
c'est un scandale
0-2 avant les toiles suivante c'est
comme si une fille canon passé sous les
yeux comme ce à quoi on était homosexuel
c'est incroyable comment j'arrive pas à
parler en même temps de jouer
aujourd'hui les enfants c'est à dire que
c'est tellement à sa demande tellement
de ressources psychiques cette connerie
d un et deux et trois raté mais je
comprends pas qu'on vous pouvez faire
plus rapide que ce à quoi
c'est un truc impossible sans les
connaît regardez regardez moi ça et les
mots suivants attendait un garde qui
vole carrément a voulu mettre 2 shuriken
alors là c'est ma petite fierté
aujourd'hui ni plus ni moins niveau
suivant
j'ai peur ou alors juste et voilà le
cieux mais que demande le peuple
ok c'est parti à ce stop wii motion que
le boss de la maj [ __ ] c'est quoi ce
bordel
oh la vache au plat salé ou tommy
entournures tombe à plat
baa à plat des gages à plat dégage le
cube de la mort
merci à vous tous d'être venus de rien
enfin on m'a forcé à venir sera pas un
gros mot hitler c'est urgent windjet à
bord oui on va vous défoncer au place
alliage en place à des gains à toi y ait
des portails mais qui prouve
aux deux étoiles taxe locale sur le cas
dès qu'on arrive sur i can et à ba3 et
toi ok si tu vas faire match nul
oh là là non mais les gars là là sports
possibles à eau avec ou plus à la
rapidité l'état qui est en moi ces
niveaux suivants je pleure tac tac en
place dès que j'en sors un autre le
deuxième 3 des trois casquettes pas ce
monsieur
ok j'ai compris ok on descend been
choquent un certain 1er court aux jeux
la méthode coué chapuis de toute ma vie
c'est incroyable oh ça fait mal ça pique
je dois avoir dit c'est peut-être quand
je travaillais mon gars mais la
concentration règne au c'est le boss
d'ailleurs on a coupé en deux c'est nous
le ca ca c nous cet homme on est face à
une armée c'est ça et j'appuie ma main
sur le siège comme ça je le presse
tellement je suis tendu on les regarde
dans les yeux et nous regardent dans les
yeux ils deviennent tous bleus abordent
à tuer le méchant ils sont tous gentils
maintenant on a gagné félicitations
bravo à vous merci de m'avoir permis
d'avoir un très léger style durant cette
vidéo mon cerveau est en totale
surchauffe j'arrive plus à parler à
jouer en même temps tellement je vais me
concentrer c'était ignoble c'est
dégueulasse j'espère quand même que ça
vous a plu et ses cannes stp avait la
vidéo je suis un [ __ ] de gros try
harder j'étais j'ai joué ma vie
aujourd'hui voilà verse alors gardons
sens très bien dans une prochaine vidéo
chat vous portez vous bien pis